but let's get to the the the escalation
of this by throwing it to our good
friend matt walsh
matt walsh tweeted these hearings on
abortion are instructive the liberal
witnesses have refused to condemn
infanticide refused to define the word
woman and claim that men can get
pregnant we cannot share a country with
these people there can be no unity they
are lunatics and monsters i don't
respect them i have nothing in common
with them i detest everything they
believe and stand for they feel the same
about me we simply cannot go on this way
matt previously had tweeted we are a
nation divided over whether pregnant men
exist the coming civil war will
certainly be the weirdest one in history
so
it may be a bit silly
a lot of people keep denying the reality
of what's happening in this country but
um i i don't think matt's wrong when he
says he detests them i certainly believe
he does but they feel the same way about
him they certainly do
so at a certain point we are inching
towards what many people refer to as at
the very least peaceful divorce
peaceful peaceful development i have a
chapter of that in my book right there
will be back phone rise of america i
have to mention it like every time
because otherwise regnary will keep my
family hostage
uh but so so real quick i wanna ask you
about that but um i we talked about this
a while back that abortion could be the
moral catalyst like slavery was
and
some people might not think so
maybe maybe not it could be a
combination of things i i think it's
possible that we're in the bleeding
kansas phase of civil war that was the
seven so not quite we're we're not
shooting yet but i do talk about we're
not aaron danielson was shot twice in
the chest in portland that's true not in
a systemic way i i don't i don't agree i
think the issue is when you look back at
bleeding kansas this was this was an era
where we didn't have the kind of
communications or technology true
so
people are more tactful in their
strategies for warfare
which is they're trying to manipulate
people to gain public power and access
to resources and direct violence doesn't
work as effectively or it doesn't it's
not it's not effective at all at all
these days in most circumstances so when
you look at the past several years when
you look at the 529 insurrection when
leftists broke the barricades down in
front of the white house set fire to
saint john's church torched the guard
post and forced the president into a
bunker and then the media defended it
i i pulled up an article from 529 this
was mind-blowing and it said that the
democrats wanted an inquiry on the
police actions that's right after the
left firebombed a church and a guard
post and the president was forced in the
bunker the democrats were like we need
to know what the police were doing well
and they did do that investigation right
yeah well and then you get january 6
which is the which is
all of a sudden now it's the apocalypse
i i i feel that look for those i don't
know bleeding kansas was a territorial
it was kansas there was a civil war
effectively within the state over
whether or not it would be a slave state
and it never stopped believing kansas
didn't end the civil war just started no
no the bleeding kansas i talked about in
there was
essentially
dispersed decentralized cavalry units
raiding various civilian outposts and
there were a large number of deaths look
you are right that the pre poetic
predicate
uh condition
does exist that is people in significant
numbers accepting the use of
intimidation and violence to affect
political change and we see that even we
even saw it this week with uh you know
i'm going to go get in uh getting
kavanaugh's face as he's eating a rib
eye because ribeye of course fantastic
they're in a tenderloin
his face now if you get in someone's
face you're not persuading him you're
trying to force him to go your way you
have left politics you have left
persuasion you've left you know uh
the the system you're now using
intimidation so if you get his face
where is the moral
uh guardrail that keeps you from
slapping his face to make him do it and
if that doesn't work
where is the guardrail that keeps you
from shooting him in the face so you are
there was an assassin and there was
there was so you are correct there are a
significant number who are accepting the
premise that you can use violence to
affect change keep in mind 50 years ago
we had a low-grade urban insurgency we
had the weather underground black
panthers symbiones liberation army death
to the fascist insect the greatest
greatest tagline for a revolutionary
group ever
and it was treated as a law enforcement
matter but there were bombings all over
the place read days of rage bombings all
over the place a large number of
killings it was suppressed through law
enforcement but that was a very low
grade type of insurgency when i talk
about civil war and i i discuss i have
two chapters i discuss read on
red against a blue government blew
against a uh a red people
uh or a red government um
you know there is a spectrum of conflict
but you are correct about the predicate
which is people accepting the idea that
violence is an acceptable means to
affect political change and
unfortunately there are a number of
people on the left who do that i i don't
know
how great that number is
doesn't matter how many people it does
matter because if it becomes if it
starts getting 40 50 percent then you've
got a real problem how many people
fought in the civil war
see that's that's when it becomes 40 50
60 70 80 10 yes but the people supported
them so
in our situation like who would be out
there fighting so the question is
depending on the center front versus
antifa that's bleeding kansas that is
bleeding kansas and that is one of the
things small
informal militias battling it out what's
the government does the government send
in the cap yeah we have but no but not
in large we did see it
it does exist
but it's in pieces but it's not systemic
we had we had rioting in portland for
120 days yes firebombing federal
buildings yes correct we had since what
since when did it start 2017 oh yeah the
battle for berkeley right right right
the the the chas
in multiple varieties even even until
recently you had the autonomous zone in
many minneapolis
look
people were shot and killed they they
lit up a white suv with like hundreds of
rounds of five five six because
teenagers read it and they heard a fake
report on the radio from cops that white
supremacists were going to come and
attack them look there
are the conditions
are
i don't think they're interested
in provo utah right i think provost was
called yeah they had the ship blm ran up
a supporter ran up to a car and shot a
driver for no reason yes these these
things they happening they exist
but they're not systemic fighting
of the kind
that we saw in bleeding kansas but they
could become it and they right now
they're in urban environments where you
have a unique uh set of conditions you
always have a d.a who won't prosecute
you always have a weak government you
always have a a police
force that is
unwilling or unable to take action
and interestingly even when uh they were
talking about sending in military forces
and i was part of the military force
that suppressed the la riots so i i have
seen this in operation i've seen it
happen i was part of it
um you have uh governors who simply will
not cooperate with that
so
that's where it starts to get crazy it
does start to get crazy
we haven't got there yet
i'm
my contention is we could get there
i'd like to take the off-ramp and not
get there what's the off-ramp yeah what
is that well look the the obvious
off-ramp is to convince enough uh
convince a critical mass of americans to
go back to uh essentially the rule of
law and the constitution
but then we do that and they disagree
with the premise of the constitution
well
how many do we're going to find out we
read all assumptions they talk about
this all in school right because thomas
jefferson was a slave oh yeah and so we
have to disagree yeah
they want to increase the number of
people who have this uh
disgusting marxist critique of the uh
constitution yes and and and if they
succeed yeah we're gonna have a real
problem and i don't know if they
succeeded yeah what's his name like
ellie miss doll or yeah
who's going to read ellie well he's all
over his heart he's all over msnbc all
the time who watches msnbc a lot of
people weirdos losers and mutations i
don't know but what they should do is go
together these are the people
who you're saying we're going to be
fighting right the people who watch
msnbc msnbc's ratings are like 100k it's
like really abysmal and then it's like
people in their 60s
so uh yesterday ladies yesterday i
pulled up an article explaining the
sentiment for union support for the
civil war and you know what the the view
is at least according to this historical
like reference the view was the union
thought the confederacy had been taken
over by a conspiracy of elites that were
subverting the constitutional rights of
the people and that they had to free
these states from an elite conspiracy
they they believed that uh these elites
were denying personhood rights
and i said oh
that sounds like something a trump
supporter would say about today that
democrats are subverting the
constitution locking down churches that
they're denying personhood to babies i
was like it's not one for one but
there's a parallel the reason why i say
bleeding kansas phase is not to claim
that literally bleeding kansas is
happening one for one like it's
identical it's that we're in the
escalation of conflict pre-civil war
which eventually
it's the violence that occurs before a
formal civil war and the reason why i
say that
for one everything we've already said
but but my point is
we can't expect everything happening now
to be identical to what happened back
then for a variety of reasons i mean
technology is one the other issue is
that we are not arguing over which
states will enter the union and support
a cause we're talking about which states
already do actively support abortion to
the point of birth or even after birth
like like virginia tried to do with with
northam
those those those states are already
ideologically in those camps so it's
looking more like a spanish civil war
or maybe a candidate no it's ideological
it's not geographic
but it's not just against left
it's becoming geography although i don't
see us as philangists it's becoming
geographically take a look at
minneapolis so we talked about the other
day there's a video you may have seen of
the fat old dude in tighty whities
twerking in front of a little girl and a
woman walk up to a little girl and waves
and no motions a little girl a little
girl waves
that happened in public in full view of
parents they they wanted the little girl
to engage with it
but i guarantee you
if i give that video i took it and i
went to an advertising agency and said i
want this it's a pride event in public
with families and kids it's it's
wholesome nobody's nude they're all
fully clothed and i wanted on a
billboard in times square they would say
get out of this building this is
disgusting
but
why is it then that it would be allowed
in public in these cities
where are the people like us that would
say that's bad to actually be on the
ground in those places to tell them to
stop why is it that liberty posted this
video a father said i'm going to read
for you this book and the guy said you
can't read that it's illegal and he said
but it's in our schools
why is it that these things are being
allowed to happen it's because the
culture in these places
has moved to a degree where they accept
these things regardless of law
when the law stops being enforced and
that that's what we're seeing oh yes
then eventually you'll see similar
arguments we saw in the civil war which
is why are we party to a to a a country
in which the law is only enforced
against us but never against those who
wrong us you're look you are absolutely
correct you're talking about the
predicate conditions for civil conflict
and one of them is a dual-track justice
system which we are seeing in space i
mean look at look at the j6 people
that's just you know guys sitting in
there in in jail for a year and a half
where's their speedy trial for their
misdemeanors it is
and it is unsustainable now
how are we going to solve it well one
way i solve it is
political action we either
have a courts that stand up and do the
right thing
or we have elections
where we take power back and you know
the next president pardons all these
guys
or
we go outside the political process and
outside the political process
which is where you've accurately pointed
the left has gone
well that that can be really scary and
there is a continuum of that there is a
continuum of of civil conflict and i
look i
and it worries the hell out of me
because as you know i served in kosovo
served where there was a a civil war we
earned the ruins of it and i would walk
through ruined villages and i i remember
one village it looked like just blown
blown down just bombed down i said wow
this told my muslim interpreter man this
is horrible but i don't see any blast
marks on any flame marks and he said no
no no the the enemy of this town came
here with crowbars and sledgehammers and
literally disassembled this town into
wreckage that was the level of hatred i
was i was reading about the french
revolution and i was reading about
robespierre and danton i think yeah you
mentioned
and the crazy thing about it
is that uh i'm wrong because i think you
were reading about this it was basically
a bunch of people terrified of each
other
thinking if i don't kill them they'll
kill me
it's usually what it comes to i think
robespierre eventually turned on his
brother in arms which was danton the two
of them together
sparked the revolution and then dan uh
danton just was like hey robespierre
you're becoming too much of a cult
leader it's not about you it's about the
revolution and rupture it was like i'm a
better speaker than you and you'll be
executed and then nobody would stand up
to defend him there's a quote i read
they said
they cared less about their convictions
and more about presenting their virtue
oh they were feared like what's going on
now they they they feared that if they
spoke up and said this is wrong they
would be condemned along with him and he
was executed for it danton was executed
and that's when i i i was reading into
this because i saw a quote from i think
it was a plato maybe where he said
something uh what's the quote i tweeted
it that uh the the penalty for refusing
to be engaged is to be ruled by evil men
or something that affects yes and then i
remembered the quote from danton
uh what do you what did he say oh it is
better to be a fisherman than medal in
the government of yeah or a poor farmer
i think he said poor fisherman fisherman
was it yeah and accentuating the poor to
be in poverty than to be metal in the
politics and so i was like pick your
poison right do nothing and be ruled by
evil meddle get your head chopped off
and so i started reading about danton
and robespierre and it really like i
read a cursory article talking about it
and it was really very much like these
disparate factions were all it was a
mexican standoff they were all staring
at each other like which one is going to
be the one that tries to kill us next so
then they were like sounds like the
spanish civil war on the communist side
yeah because when they weren't fighting
franco's guys they were killing each
other i mean in in probably why frank
ended up winning right franco did franco
won pretty darn decisively um
and that is one of the one of the
problems with the left
the you know they when they're engaged
you know you you've got to win or you
die for kind of the conservative side
they don't really want to be engaged
so it's not you know
forrest cooper
he said that uh the people who are good
at violence don't want to be involved in
it and that should tell you something
that is true the guys who have seen it
who've experienced it who are trained in
it are like please stop please stop
one of the problems with the left
is
well i i mean i mean look at the
look at the oval day uh footage of the
cops dating yeah that's
milling around for i you know
that's one untrained little mutant 18
years old
not not tactically proficient he's got
he's got a weapon
but there's like 20 of them
and and they won't rush him what are
they going to do
about 400 000 guys who are trained and
who are ideologically committed and who
aren't 18. even a few thousand you ever
tried building a house because even five
like what would they do against five
guys
okay what happened in boston right two
mutants
two little mutants that's right shut
down boston
two guys with handguns and the
occasional pressure cooker bomb shut
down boston have you ever tried to build
a house of cards
you know you get planned yeah sure it's
it's it's it's tough it takes a lot of
time and energy yeah and then someone
can go
yep a tiny tiny and the whole thing
comes crumbling down my point is it is
extremely difficult to build a complex
machine it is extremely easy to disrupt
one i look at it as a jenga tower you
know the little game you have little
blocks and the leftists
first of all y'all understand the
leftist our ruling class inherits this
jenga tower they didn't build it they're
cultural trust fund babies it was handed
to them they got their credentials at
harvard
and then they took their jobs running
the institutions which they have no
particular appreciation or or even
understanding of they just got it and
they use them for their own power and
they think they could pull out these
things from the jenga tower because it
never never occurred to them how hard it
is to build that tower and it never
occurred to him that could possibly
collapse but it can and that's been
going on for a long time it's been going
on since the 70s there's this great play
by jules pfeiffer called little murders
and uh i don't know if you know the play
but um
everything's getting destroyed in new
york city and it's this wild story where
uh the police are trying to figure out
who there's like a shooter every time
you go outside people are getting shot
the murders are just skyrocketing as
they were in new york city and you have
the police being like this is a
conspiracy to make the police look bad
because we can't figure out who's
killing everybody but one of the
characters is finally just like destroy
destroy destroy when are you gonna find
time to build and it's like
all of these all of these people have
taken over the institutions camille
paglia talked about this as well she
said the real marxists went out and
lived on communes and all of the fakers
ended up in the universities that's true
that uh that that's absolutely true you
do you think in the uh in the age of uh
uh bug protein they're not gonna be able
to get themselves a top sirloin right
they're gonna they're gonna be able to
do hunter biden is always gonna be able
to get a top sirloin and a nice piece of
ass always going to be vitally important
that leonardo dicaprio fly to davos to
lecture us on our
carbon footprint
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there